To solve this problem, I broke it up into two parts.
Let's think of this section where we're accelerating first then calculate how far we go.
Well, this is the equation I want to use and so I know I'm looking for Δx.
And I know the initial velocity is 0, and the time is 4 s for this first part of the question,
and the acceleration will be 3.
When I carry out this math, I find that I covered a distance of 24 m in the first 4 s.
But I want to go 96 m, so I still have 72 m left to go at a constant speed of 12 m/s.
Well, I can use the same exact equation, but now I know Δx and not the time.
So notice that now I've used an initial velocity of 12.
Even though my first problem started with an initial velocity of 0, I've broken it up.
So the second smaller subproblem has an initial velocity of 12 and no acceleration.
So this term goes to 0. I can solve this and find that t = 6 s.
And I have to add that to my original 4 s, so it takes me 10 s to complete this race.